Speaker 1: Well, I hope everybody who celebrated
had a good Thanksgiving. I will talk about mine
on today's bonus show very, very compelling and
exciting in different ways. We're going to hear
from Pat about his trip to Colombia. No joke
there and so many other things. But if you paid
attention at all to the news over the Thanksgiving
holiday, you certainly must know by now
that you must bow down to the Omicron COVID
variant. Never leave your house again.
Hide from this brutal, deadly variant, which
will kill everyone and destroy the economy. Well,
hold on a second. Let's actually back up for a
bit. Is it possible it will be that bad? Yes. At
any point, we don't want to belittle the fact that
the possibility that we could get an extremely
deadly variant. But the story that has been more
or less the corporate media story so far starting
on Friday, which by the way, led to the worst day
for stocks of the year as a result of the panic,
with the Dow Jones Industrial Average down more
than two and a half percent. The Russell 2000
index down nearly four percent. I mean, just
a disastrous day for stocks on the basis of
Omicron. What is the truth of it? The truth is
we don't really yet know almost anything about it
that would lead us to say, this is it for being
out of our houses. This is it for being able to
sort of be living mildly more normal lives. This
is it for the economy. We just the corporate
media panic which affected the stock market was
very much ahead of itself, and we're going to
talk about that. So first, let's talk about the
cuts. Could the Omicron variant be more deadly
than any other? Sure, it could. Could the Omicron
variant be more transmissible? Sure, it could be.
And that may be the one element of it that we are
closest to knowing about at this point in time.
It's possible that it's way more transmissible.
Does the Omicron variant make the current vaccines
useless? It's possible that that could be the
case. But we do not know any of that right now.
And the panic is serving No. One Well, now there
are some in the audience who might say, well,
the panic is good because it's getting people
ready to lockdown or whatever. I disagree. I
don't think that the panic at this point, absent
actual information, is doing anybody any good.
So let's talk about what we actually know
about the new variant. First question
is it? Let's actually look at the possibilities
of what it could be and what we know so,
Dr. Eric Topol tweeted over the weekend. Important
message from Dr. Lascelles, a leading South
African infectious disease specialist now, Dr.
Lascelles wrote, Quote just the note of caution.
We know that getting a rapid understanding of
disease severity with Omicron, particularly in
vaccinated individuals and reinfections, is
absolutely critical, but it's just too early
for reliable data. Anecdotally, we're hearing
from some in South Africa that Omicron variant
symptoms are, quote, unusual but mild. But that's
not something to hang our hats on yet, either.
That could be because it is more young people so
far hit with this variant in South Africa. Now
it's already all over the world,
identified in Canada, Germany, Belgium,
Hong Kong, the United Kingdom. It's probably in
the United States, says Dr. Anthony Fauci. So
it's all we've seen these containment measures
basically punishing southern Africa, and it's
already all over the place. And that doesn't
seem to be doing too much, but we do not yet know
whether the symptoms will be more severe or more
mild. Remember that in general, coronaviruses
tend to get more transmissible and less severe
over time. Becoming a really spreadable cold
can take years can take years. As
Dr. Vincent Racaniello told us,
the real headline is not one that causes
panic and clicks and stock market declines,
which is the headline from science
from this weekend, which is called
very boringly. Patience is crucial. Why we won't
know for weeks how dangerous Omicron is now. One
issue is that Omicron is rapidly replacing other
variants in South Africa, so that's seen as a bad,
bad sign. It's very quickly out competing. Other
variants now that's possible that it could be
because it's more transmissible and or more.
More serious, it could also be due to chance,
it could also be due to skewed testing or
a number of other things we don't know yet.
Omicron could evade vaccine immunity and natural
antibodies. It could, and that would be terrible.
However, the number of mutations allowed
alone don't actually tell us that.
But the general view so far is that if you have
been vaccinated or recovered naturally from a
previous variant, you would likely have some
protection against Omicron. We don't yet know
how much there might be a drop. It could be a
bigger drop than with other variants, we don't
know. Now we got an update this morning from the
show, and the show is being very clear about all
the things we do not know. Quote It is not yet
clear whether Omicron is more transmissible.
It is not yet clear whether infection with
Omicron causes more severe disease compared
to prior variants. Preliminary evidence suggests
there may be an increased risk of reinfection
with Omicron compared to other variants. We don't
yet know. Same with vaccines we don't yet know.
That's the update as of just an hour ago. So
in all seriousness, let's not ignore this.
I am not saying Don't worry about it, guys. Let's
wait and see. And in the meantime, let's behave
logically for the circumstances and facts that
we know. Last thing CEO Albert Bourla from Pfizer
says Pfizer has already started to develop
a new COVID vaccine tailored to the Omicron
variant. Take a look at this when
Speaker 2: it comes to the vaccine
remains to be seen. I don't think that the result
will be in the vaccines don't protect. I think
the results could be, which we don't know yet. But
the vaccines protect less, which means that if the
vaccines protect less, it is that if we need to
create a new vaccine already and we started Friday
Friday, we made our first DNA template,
which is the first part of the manufacturing
of the development process of a new vaccine.
And we have made multiple times clear that we
will be able to have a vaccine in less
than 100 days. In fact, we have already
two vaccines built in less than three days.
Speaker 1: So, you know, we keep hearing
this kind of 100 day. No, Moderna has said
something similar, so that's something that
is being worked on. But let's go by what the data
shows. And so far, what the data shows is there's